hello everyone today we're going to
look at some news in the machine
learning
world the wall street journal here
writes google unit deepmind tried and
failed to win ai autonomy from parent so
apparently
deepmind has sought to become more
independent of google
in the past and here they write that
it's been founded in 2010
and bought by google in 2014 and
starting in 2015 there were already
talks as far as we want to be more
independent
now apparently deepmind told staff late
last month that
google has called off those talks here
it says deepmind's founders had sought
among other ideas a
legal structure used by non-profit
groups reasoning that the powerful
artificial intelligence they were
researching
shouldn't be controlled by a single
corporate entity
on the other hand from google's point of
view the proposed structure didn't make
financial sense for alphabet given its
total investment in the unit and its
willingness to bankroll deepmind so
deepmind sold itself to google
because of money needs their research
consumes ginormous quantities
of energy and of researchers and that
costs a lot of money so they cashed in
500 billion
as a price said it bought the startup
for 500 million
and the losses of the company were about
660 million dollars this company makes
giant losses because what they do is
essentially pr
so the position of google here is that
they want to bring the teams closer
together and have a stronger
impact rather than separating the teams
this is an asset to google a tech asset
so for deepmind it's pretty easy to push
for a non-profit
structure given that you know they will
never make profit ever
and their claims to wanting to be open
and not in the hands of a single thing i
could take it more seriously
if they were ever to publish in
open access journals which they don't
they publish in nature oh you gotta pay
20 bucks for that article
thanks deepmind surely you don't want
the technology to fall into the
hands of a select few if they were to
actually
open source their code and not just some
crappy pseudo code that has lots of
mistakes in it i'm sure you want to just
distribute that stuff out of there
because if it's just in the hand of a
single minority
that would be terrible right right no
i think what they want is they recognize
they got something good going there they
got someone paying for their bills and
they don't want someone
from top down telling them hey make it
more into a product
hey give it to us we need it to make
money
what are you talking about google wants
this technology in their products as
fast as possible
as best as possible and deep mind
researchers are just
really really smart people that output
these things
lastly i want to show you this rendering
of the proposed
new deep mind offices in here like if
that is not
the most dystopian future
picture i've ever seen i mean it does
look cool but it is a bit on the
elitist side i would feel it's a cool
office like
sure i take it absolutely great what i'm
saying is
you want this on one hand but then also
you want giant loss making and
independence on the other hand
maybe that's not possible at the same
time i'm just not really sure that
that is the reason deep mind seeks
independence all right that was it for
me this is already too long tell me what
you
think in the comments what your deep
mind do what you google do who's the
good guy who's the bad guy
how should ai benefit all of humanity or
are we all doomed
peace out
you